und nicht nur wegen dieser Situation
sondern vor allem auch wegen ganz vielen
anderen Situation noch zusätzlich in
Deutschland verspüren Sie ja Herr Funke
eine Radikalisierung der Bürger besser
gesagt sie glauben dass es Protesten
kommen könnte die haben wir ja zum Teil
schon das muss man ja sehen mich stimmen
immer nachts nachdenklich wenn ich mir
Niedersachsen jetzt eine Wahlbeteiligung
von glaube gut 60% habe 60 kameradens
dann ist etwas faul die gehen nicht mehr
hin und zur Wahl und typischerweise
treffe ich eine am Wahltag ein Ehepaar
der Mann sagt ich bin gar nicht erst
hingegangen
so mir gefällt das alles nicht mehr
Resignation Resignation ist eigentlich
in einer Demokratie das schlimmste was
es gibt wenn jemand mit mir schimpft
dann weiß ich der ist noch engagiert wir
hatten innere Einstellung dazu mit ihm
muss ich reden den kann ich auch
vielleicht überzeugen von ihm auch etwas
lernen wenn niemand sagt komm her so das
ist das Schlimmste Zeichen eigentlich
was es gibt die Frau war wählen die
wollte mir nicht sagen was Sie gewählt
hat daraus habe ich meine Schlüssel aber
dann auch gezogen so und in dieser
Haltung ist nicht unbedingt eine
Radikalisierung aber eine signative und
das ist die Vorstufe davon dass einem
eigentlich alles egal ist und dann
profitieren die davon die wir alle
glaube ich nicht wollen das ist meine
Sorge wenn wir bei Kommunalwahlen das
läuft ja nicht erst seit einiger Zeit
Bürgermeister Landratswahlen eine
Wahlbeteiligung kam von 40 unter 40%
damit jemand Land reden über Landrat
oder Bürgermeisterin dann kann mich das
ja nicht gleichgültig lassen überhaupt
nicht ging das muss ich doch fragen
Stichwort Förderalismusreform dazu
gehörte auch unter Umständen der Reform
ist kann man einfach fassungsrechts so
fragen wie kriege ich das wieder
einigermaßen ins Lot
Frau dovidad hier ist ja man wird ja
also investigativ schon ist er
eigentlich um die Missstände in einem
Land aufzudecken auf jeden Fall wenn man
Filme schaut und das investigativ sich
anschaut die Frage die ich mir stelle
ist nehmen Sie das auch so war dass die
Stimmung in dem Land gibt total also
unser Team beschäftigt sich seit ein
paar Wochen oder eigentlich schon
Monaten ganz intensiv genau mit dieser
Frage zum Beispiel jetzt akuter mit
kommt jetzt ein wutherbs kommt ein
wutwintern damit ist ja genau das
gemeint gehen die Leute jetzt mehr auf
die Straße weil sie das
illusioniert sind weil sie sagen die
Politik erreicht uns nicht mehr die
hilft uns auch gar nicht mehr und wir
erleben das halt wirklich die Leute die
da eben auch zu sehen waren in den
Bildern die Leute da auf die Straße
gehen das sind ganz oft
Menschen die zum Beispiel hat man gerade
letzte Woche eine Geschichte über ein
Unternehmer der in einer ganz ähnlichen
Situation war wie sie der selber so ein
Protest auf die Beine gestellt hat der
sagt nee ich kann damit nichts mehr
anfangen was mir die Volksparteien
bieten und das ist eben genau die Stunde
der Populisten das spielt der AFD
zu und
schlimmstenfalls eben Leute die auch
völlig außerhalb des demokratischen
Spektrums sind die all diese Menschen
die in diesem querdenkerspektrum sind
das sind ja jetzt die die vielleicht
schon angefangen haben sich 2015 nach
der flüchtlingskrise zu radikalisieren
die es dann weiter getan haben mit der
corona-krise und die jetzt sagen
in der aktuellen Situation habe ich
einfach gar keine Lust mehr und das
beunruhigt die Sicherheitsbehörden
Verfassungsschutz und so absolut mit den
sprechen wir immer darüber was seht ihr
da für ein radikalisierungspotenzial und
das ist eines der größten Probleme was
für politisch bei uns momentan haben das
all den Informationen die Sie bekommen
und auch Recherchen kommt der Wut Herbst
ich würde sagen er ist teilweise schon
da man sieht es ja wie die Leute auf die
Straßen gehen und es bleibt nur zu
hoffen dass es nicht wirklich zu so
gewaltsame Ausschreitungen Attacken auf
Politiker oder so führt
als Politiker sind sie ja eigentlich der
Betroffene von der Kritik der Bürger was
müsste die Politik tun
drei Sachen erstens
wir Politiker müssen ganz ganz nah beim
Bürger sein ganz nah aber sind sie das
noch
also ich rufe jeden an habe mich noch
nie durchstellen lassen bin auf vielen
Veranstaltungen
mailen noch persönlich also wenn morgen
Mails kommen da antworte ich das Produkt
machen
ich versuche so nah wie möglich wirklich
dran zu sein und ich glaube auch mal ein
rundes Bar ist gerade in der Kneipe ja
und lass mich danach zwei drei Bier dass
die Leute mal wirklich die Wahrheit
sagen etc ja ich bin ja auch Bürger es
geht mir auch gegen den Strich was hier
in Deutschland passiert ich spüre das ja
wenn Sie jetzt noch 10 % Inflation haben
überlegen Sie mal was was hier los sein
kann und deswegen ist es aber meine
Aufgabe hier keine Ängste zu schnüren
sondern das zu sehen und zu agieren dass
der erste Punkt der zweite Punkt wir
müssen uns einfach mit den Themen
beschäftigen sie haben das eben
angesprochen die die Bürger umtreibt das
ist einfach so und nicht diese diese
also ob jetzt noch Indianer gesagt
werden darf oder ob das rassistisch ist
oder ob ein Lied wie Layla öffentlich
gespielt werden kann
Wahnsinn
Wahnsinn kann das sein Bürger wollen
wissen Debatten aus die Politik so ein
bisschen von sozialen Netzwerken
getrieben ist weil dann so Leute bei
Twitter sind die sagen Layla darf nicht
mehr gespielt werden man darf nicht mehr
Indianer sagen obwohl es eigentlich gar
nicht so die wirkliche Bevölkerung
widerspiegelt ist auch ein Grund warum
ich warum ich nicht bei Twitter bin weil
ich zwei drei Jahren gesagt hat ein Kind
was kein Deutsch kann hat auf der
Grundschule nicht zu suchen es muss
gefördert werden über eine
vorschulpflicht bei Twitter hatte ich 80
90 Prozent gegen mich aber mit
vollkaracho aber richtig hart rechte
Ecke ich wäre rassistisch etc heute ist
übrigens Partei Meinung übrigens auch
ein konservativer Punkt um junge
Menschen einzeln zu fördern seitdem bin
ich nicht mehr bei Twitter weil ich will
ich will mich hier nicht beeinflussen
lassen will meine Meinung sagen so und
die Leute wollen wissen ist das Geld
sicher ist der Job sicher und die
Zukunft meiner Kinder das sind die drei
Punkte und nichts anderes das sind alles
Randthemen die so hochgezogen werden
dass die Leute das Gefühl haben das ist
die öffentliche Meinung es ist aber nur
die veröffentlichte Meinung und der
dritte Punkt und der letzte Punkt ist
das Thema Arbeit und nicht arbeiten das
treibt mich richtig um
das in Deutschland nicht Arbeit sich in
immer mehr Fällen lohnt im Vergleich zur
Arbeit wenn jetzt das neue Bürgergeld
kommt Sanktionen abgeschaffen werden
dann ist ja das gesamte
soziale Prinzip es fußt darauf dass
diejenigen die Steuern zahlen unsere
Sozialstaat finanzieren genau
das heißt wir haben ja auch eine
Verantwortung gegenüber den Menschen die
unsere Sozialsystem finanzieren wenn die
aber jetzt sehen das mit dem Geld nicht
vernünftig umgegangen wird das gesagt
wird es ist besser ich arbeite nicht
wenn wir dort noch die die
Heizkostenrechnung übernommen und vieles
mehr dann stimmt etwas nicht mehr und
dann sagt diese Gruppe ich mache da
nicht mehr mit und da müssen wir
aufpassen gerade in der heutigen Zeit
und da haben wir Parteien auch eine
Verantwortung Klartext zu reden wenn die
Leute das Gefühl haben es gibt keine
Unterschiede mehr zwischen den Parteien
dann sagen die warum soll ich noch
wählen gehen
Wahlkampf von wählen und ich kann nur
wählen wenn es Unterschiede gibt und
deswegen war zum Beispiel die große
Koalition die ist Gift für eine
Demokratie die dafür ist eigentlich so
gut wie gar nicht geben weil die
Menschen dann die Alternativen nicht
mehr sehen und dann wählen Sie Protest
und deswegen
finde ich müssen wir an diesen drei
Punkten ansetzen und dann kriegen auch
wieder Vertrauen sagen sie heute als
CDU-Vize nicht in eine große Koalition
gehen bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl
ich würde es nicht raten nein
wir brauchen klar das darf nicht zu
lange sein ja wir brauchen wieder
Parteien mit ganz klaren Positionen dass
wir uns auch wieder streiten das ist
nicht darum geht wer wer hat jetzt die
hübschesten Fotografen oder Fotos oder
Instagram
über das Buch reden sehr gut aber
überlegen Sie mal wann hatten wir die
höchsten Wahlbeteiligung wenn wir
komplett strackige Themen hatten wo
zumindest die großen Lager mit Ausnahmen
die es dabei auch gab mal wie bei den
Ostverträgen so hohe Wahlbeteiligung in
den Wahlen weil die Menschen Position
beziehen wollten zu den Positionen die
vertreten werden sie Verwandten den
Begriff Populismus da habe ich meine
Schwierigkeiten ja für mich sind das die
popularen waren im alten Rom die
Vertreter des einfachen Volkes die
optimalen die Vertreter der herrschenden
Schicht und ich meine Populismus jeder
sein der gewählt werden will das fängt
ist Kleingartenvereins an wenn der nicht
auch Populist ist kriegt er nie mehr
alten zustande
das Volk von mir möchte und nicht dass
ich das nicht das tue von dem ich
wirklich überzeugt bin
ein bedeutungsmanager
Populisten oder populanten sehr klar der
Populist will etwas durchsetzen und legt
sich jetzt seine Argumente so zurecht
dass er dafür eine Mehrheit bekommt er
hat seine Position
Willy Brandt hatte seine Position oder
Franzosen Strauß nehmen wir mal die
großen Populisten in meinen Augen hatten
eine Frau Kohl eine Position und dafür
jetzt zu werben rhetorische Instrumente
einzusetzen
verantwortlich
Populisten
gucken wie geht denn wohl die Meinung
und das ist das gefährliche ich komme in
den Sa Glocke wie denkt denn hier die
Kohorte und dann lange ich zu damit ich
weiß du bist ganz schnell beifallen darf
ich meine Meinung dem anpasse was ich
denke das nützt mir jetzt am meisten und
irgendwann Überzeugung handle ist es ja
in Ordnung so und das darf ich nicht der
Populist der sagt ich muss hier nicht
mehr Halt kriegen aber er hat seine
Position verlieren wird und dann ist
Lindemann besser als Funkel seine
Position findet eine Mehrheit so
Opportunismus
könnte hier wohl besser ankommen ich
übernehmen die mal eben und jetzt zum
nächsten Mal und erzählt genau das
Gegenteil bei der merkt die Leute
irgendwas Gott sei Dank spüren die Leute
aber es dauert zu